depuis bermut les bombardements de
soledar sont visibles et audibles c'est
de localité de la région de deniesk
qu'une quinzaine de kilomètres séparent
sont devenus le théâtre le plus sanglant
de la guerre selon l'Ukraine
ce matin vous avez quasiment plus
personne dans la rue quasiment tous les
immeubles sont endommagés détruits les
façades calcinées
la ville de soledar qui abritait les
plus grandes mines de celles d'Europe
née désormais qu'un champ de ruines ou
un de mes milliers de personnes ont
décidé malgré tout de rester pour la
Russie soledar demeure une prise
importante la valeur stratégique de
soleda vient de cette affront que subit
la Russie depuis des mois à ne pas
arriver à s'emparer d'une ville si
petite il y a quand même certains
avantages militaires aussi qui sont vus
avec cette ville là dans la mesure où ça
permettra de contrôler certaines lignes
d'approvisionnement de logistique
notamment pour poursuivre l'offensive
russe de plus en plus à l'ouest dans
cette région
cette prise est revendiquée par les
mercenaires du groupe Wagner et démenti
par l'Ukraine
le président volody mirzelinski a
d'ailleurs promis de fournir tout le
nécessaire à ses soldats dans les
devises
ont bien dit qu'il y a des hommes de
Wagner et qu'ils avancent en direction
des positions ukrainiennes ils se font
ils sont tués en nombre à vrai dire
d'après ce que décrivent les Ukrainiens
mais en faisant ça ils permettent de
révéler les positions de tir ukrainienne
qui sont ensuite attaqués par la
deuxième ligne de Wagner extrêmement
coûteuse mais qui va dans l'approche
générale de la Russie qui est de miser
beaucoup sur les soldats un peu
essentiellement comme une characanon un
changement de tactique militaire rue sur
le terrain
appuyé par la nomination des nouveaux
générales à la tête du commandement
militaire je pense le changement de
garde avec la promotion entre guillemets
du général girassimov signifie un
changement tactique parce que l'ancien
général avait une posture beaucoup plus
défensive d'ailleurs le renseignement
ukrainien redoute une offensive russe
dans les prochains mois le pays compte
consolider ses positions grâce à
l'armement qu'il espère recevoir de ses
alliés pour maintenir leur intégrité
territoriale et libérée des ongles qui
sont présentement sous occupation russe
ont besoin davantage de soucis
militaires notamment avec des blindés
notamment avec d'autres soutiens de
défense aériennes
à l'ouest près de la frontière Belarus
des soldats Ukrainiens effectuent des
exercices militaires un autre front a
surveiller car plus de 10000 soldats
russes y sont rassemblés ici Yasmine
Hayat Radio-Canada Montréal